[موسيقى]
لما كلمته بالهاتف قال انا اودع عائلتي
للذهاب الى العمره
هو تحدث عن العائله
يعني
هذا هذا الغريب في الامر لكن على كل هي
ذهابه الى السعوديه مع عائلته
شو يعني ماذا تريد ان تقول
قصرا يعني
الطائره الاول
يعني ايش قال هو
قال قال لم اذهب من تلقائي نفسي
[موسيقى]
وخرجت مكالمات هاتفيه فيما بعد ويبدو انه
اراد ان يعود وقيل له مستوى
وانا سمعت التسجيلات بطبيعه الحال اييي كل
ما يمكن ان اقوله ان الصوت صوت الرئيس فقط
ليس فيها تركيب حسب
الرئيس
لا لم يكن بالامكان ان يعني يكون ذلك
مقبولا بالنسبه الى التونسيين او النظام
الحالي اذا ما اذا ما قدم ضمانات وتعهدات
بعد ممارسه العمل السياسيه
يرفضون عودته باي صفه من الصفات
يعني اصحاب التواجهات الاسلام يعني
عده متشددين من اصناف مختلفه
[موسيقى]